the desolation of smaug I will start by
saying that by any objective measure
this is a better film than the last one
it is better pacing and things don't
feel as superfluous to the story the
whole thing flows much better even
though it's all it's almost three hours
long it's miles better in the villain
department pretty much all of the major
things that people were complaining
about well the first one have been
addressed and corrected
except for my major complaint about the
last one that has gotten worse when I
talked about an unexpected journey I
said how it didn't really feel like
Bilbo's story as much as it should have
been
he felt marginalized by all the extra
stuff added in but the started with him
he had enough sections where was the
focus was very clearly him this time
it doesn't feel like his movie at all in
fact if I hadn't read the book and if
the Hobbit was not part of the title I
would never assume that Bilbo was
supposed to be the main character I
would assume it's supposed to be Thorin
or at best that this is an ensemble
piece
Bilbo comes across as a particularly
useful sidekick not the main character
and what's even more infuriating about
this is that the few times that it does
truly focus on Bilbo is when the film is
at its best
Martin Freeman is so good in this part
and he brings a lightness to it there's
otherwise lacking you need to understand
that when it comes to the books the
whole tone of the thing is fundamentally
different it's a lighter adventure it's
more fun the Lord of the Rings is a war
story effectively and it's much heavier
as much darker the stakes are much
bigger and that's fine
the problem is they're making the Hobbit
with the tone that they used for the
Lord of the Rings I went to the movies
wanting the Hobbit a prequels of Lord of
the Rings what I got was the Hobbit a
prequel to the Lord of the Rings these
movies are very clearly trying to
recapture the Lord of the Rings the feel
of them the look of them everything now
here's the thing it's okay for this to
feel like a different movie marvel's got
their head around that Thor Iron Man
Captain
they're all sharing the same cinematic
universe but each of the individual
franchises feels fundamentally different
from the others that's how it should
have been with this and as I said Martin
Freeman really does bring this wonderful
lightness to the point that it's almost
like he's in a different movie but he's
the center even when his life's in
jeopardy you just get this feeling like
we're on a fun adventure and it's all
gonna be alright but then the minute the
focus goes off of him and we deal with
all of the dwarves over the politics go
out in lake town or we deal with the
oncoming necromancer suddenly it's not a
fun little venture that's all gonna be
alright now it's a building to war movie
it's not what the feel of the book was
and I want to be clear nine times out of
the ten you're better off changing it
for the movie I think if you make the
movie exactly as what was written in the
book there's no point but you have to
stay true to what the core of that
original source material was and they're
not doing that with these movies the
core of what these movies should have
been is in the heart of those moments
with Martin Freeman when he's fighting
the spiders on his own or even better
when he breaks through the the canopy
and Mirkwood when he's alone talking
with Smaug and trying to get the dragon
she's just keep talking so he can keep
himself alive can make you go haha this
is nice but these are fleeting moments
at best unexpected journey I was a
little annoyed this time
honestly I'm pissed off I incite this
whole thing was doomed to go this way
because they wanted to recapture Lord of
the Rings they didn't really want to
tell the story of The Hobbit if they
wanted to tell the story of The Hobbit
they wouldn't have been injecting all
this stuff that wasn't there originally
like Legolas look I'm fine with putting
Legolas in there as a bit of fanservice
give him a little bit of a fight scene
so you can remind everybody what a
badass he is yeah I'm gonna stand beside
the woodland King and then you call it a
day there's no story reason for him to
be showing up in Lake town in Lake town
the minute he showed up there it went
from being decent fanservice to being
purely masturbatory look I know it seems
like I'm just crapping all over the
whole thing there are decent points the
acting is still good the special effects
honestly I think are a bit better this
time than they were the last time all
those CGI is still overused so Mao
himself really well realized that
actually probably the
iolite secondary to Martin Freeman but
that does bring me to one other big
thing the ending the point at which they
chose to cut it off and start the next
movie are you kidding me look I know
it's become a trend to take a single
story and break it into multiple parts
especially if you're adapting it from a
book but I can't remember any other
story that had this much of the first
cutoff to be continued not feel but
since the Matrix sequels I'm gonna be
honest I've given up hope I'm really not
looking forward to there and back again
anymore
I'll still go see it I have a feeling
obligation to see it but I'm not looking
forward to it cuz it's not The Hobbit
and it becomes less The Hobbit with each
instalment so on that frustrated note
this council of geeks is adjourned